economía en directo américa de france a
24 daniela vamos a hablar de esta pelea
de los modos y twitter que ya llegó
hasta los tribunales no va a terminar
nada bien todo lo que ha pasado entonces
en esta novela de twitter y más esta
novela de la que hemos venido hablando
hace mucho tiempo y de la que también
anticipamos que iba a llegar a los
tribunales tarde o temprano lo hizo más
temprano que tarde porque la empresa le
pidió el martes a un tribunal de
delaware que ordene a la persona más
rica del mundo completar la compra que
había acordado por unos 44 mil millones
de dólares o 54.2 dólares por acción eso
fue acordado inicialmente y es que el
magnate se arrepintió del negocio y lo
en moscú justo cuando la empresa vale un
poco más de 26 mil millones de dólares
en bolsa casi la mitad de lo que pactó
con la excusa de que no recibió
suficiente información sobre cuentas
falsas ahora vamos a ver las reacciones
de parte y parte
inmediatamente el dueño del fabricante
de autos de lujo test la publicó un
tweet diciendo qué ironía sin decir a
qué se refería aunque fue interpretado
por internautas como una respuesta muy
clara a la demanda que a su vez promete
ser uno de los enfrentamientos legales
más grandes en la historia de wall
street pero de que lo acusan digamos
porque lo llevaron a los tribunales no
que alegan bueno entre otras cosas la
empresa se queja de que más
aparentemente pueda ser libre de cambiar
su opinión cuando él quiera destruir la
empresa y marcharse pero entre los
apartes más llamativos de esta demanda
de 62 páginas está que los abogados de
la firma de redes sociales aportaron
pruebas que van desde mensajes de texto
como es éste en el que vemos que pide al
sitio de twitter que dejen de causarle
problemas con sus declaraciones hasta
pantallazos de los tweets del
multimillonario en los que se burla del
negocio allí señalan que para más que al
parecer twitter tanto como los intereses
de sus accionistas la transacción que
acordó también el proceso judicial para
hacerla cumplir todo esto no constituye
más que un verdadero chiste elaborado
son palabras textuales sacadas de esta
sentencia o de esta mejor de esta
demanda que fue
radicada en delaware y cambiamos
entonces de tema a danny para hablar del
dólar que definitivamente no tiene
precio ni aquí en colombia y tampoco en
chile no tiene techo raúl es que volvió
a marcar máximos históricos en estos dos
países en la jornada del martes en chile
se ubicó en mil 26 pesos y en colombia
en 4 mil 625 pesos lo que hace de estos
dos países junto con argentina los más
devaluados de américa latina' en lo
corrido del año veamos los datos según
la agencia especializada bloomberg la
moneda estadounidense se ha apreciado
casi un 24 por ciento frente al peso
argentino este año 19 por ciento frente
al chileno y cerca del 14 por ciento en
comparación con este mismo período en el
caso colombiano el peso mexicano
prácticamente se ha mantenido y
solamente brasil y perú están entre las
grandes economías de la región cuyas
monedas se han podido fortalecer este
año según los analistas la volatilidad
mundial se debe al temor a que eeuu
entre en una recesión que se extienda
por todo el planeta aunque cada país
también tiene sus propias razones
locales para que haya estos así es danny
y en otros temas rusia y ucrania también
conversan hoy sobre las exportaciones de
granos un tema muy importante también
que hemos unido hablando acá claro y
porque hay que recordar también que
estos dos países son responsables de
gran parte de la producción de granos
del mundo y de la exportación también y
ucrania está denunciando que tiene unos
22 millones de toneladas atrapados en
los puertos por cuenta de la guerra de
jaén delegaciones de turquía rusia y
ucrania entonces están celebrando en
estambul una reunión con la onu como
observadora para intentar desbloquear
los un proceso que ha sido complicado y
en el que moscú y kiev exigen garantías
rusia ha reiterado que no obstaculiza la
salida de los barcos comerciales
extranjeros de puertos ucranianos y ha
dicho que está dispuesto a asistir en
este desbloqueo pero ha recalcado que
ucrania debe determinar los puertos en
el caso del gobierno ucraniano informó
que ha logrado dar salida a un total de
16 barcos cargados de cereales por el
río danubio danny indicadores las
acciones en asia terminaron mixtas los
mercados europeos bajaban hacia el
mediodía y los precios del petróleo
subían tras el desplome del martes y
todo esto tiene un solo motivo y es que
los inversionistas están ansiosos
esperando los datos de inflación en eeuu
que se darán a conocer este miércoles
más tarde cito muchísimas gracias al y
como siempre por toda la información
económica nosotros continuamos porque
eso es directo américa y vamos a entrar